last time in the good Star Trek movie a
whale of a tale it appears a probe it's
destroying the earth in the hopes of
finding the extinct comeback desperate
to hammer in an animal-rights commentary
the enterprise goes back in time to see
if they can find some they're told
time travel is dangerous despite the
fact that they've done it a billion
times before and will continue to do it
a billion times after yarr she blows
but this marine biologist will not hand
them over so evilly she will later be
banished to the same horrendous realm
that captain Decker was banished to the
whales are captured a probe is pleased
and director Leonard Nimoy is happy this
reaches an audience that lives outside
their parents basements will Shatner
have the same luck as he takes over
directing the next one well that depends
do you like ladies over fifty years old
doing a half naked fan dance hopefully
you answered no
[Music]
Oh
and now we get one of the more famous
stinkers of the Star Trek franchise Star
Trek 5 the final frontier
this movie has so much and yet so little
going on at the same time that it can't
help but result in an illogical mess the
harsh moments are funny the funny
moments are harsh the characters seem
like over-the-top cutouts of themselves
it's just curry so let's see why this
bill boldly went where no film should
have gone before we open with a
scavenger on Nimbus 3 in the neutral
zone where he seems to think he can make
more holes in the movie than the script
can
[Music]
your pain runs deep share your pain it
turns out this rider is a Vulcan named
sidewalk who has an incredible power to
take people's pain away in a matter of
seconds how good it will need that after
this movie what did you think what all
men have sought since times again
ultimate knowledge oh you're not gonna
find it in a film shatter directed man
speaking of which we see Shatner trying
to climb his own ego as it seems Kirk
and the crew are on shore leave
Okoye watches from below trying to see
if he can have a heart attack on screen
god damn you're responsible please
captain
I haven't monitoring your progress I'm
glad it it's also nice to see that the
innovative technology so often praised
on Star Trek has taken a backseat to
Wile E Coyote trademarks I want you go
pester dr. McCoy for a while back on
into three we see a scuzzy bar where
did I mention that Shatner wrote this to
mr. Shatner I don't know why you wrote
in a three-breasted catlady and Vanessa
but she doesn't seem to be all that in
poor old the cheese if she chilled with
a rundown point City but then she killed
all the main characters except for you
yes everything in Star Trek has been
building up to the sexual adventures
with me and her three friends but that
doesn't make sense
why would I can't lady mess up B but
they pay off in Star Trek because it
adds to be a gravitas and wait oh just
want to see this disgusting thing I'm
screened in to justify scenes where one
for to dumb shit there you still got it
gentlemen I'm gaben dog so it turns out
I can I can't believe I'm saying this a
Romulan a human and a Klingon walk into
a bar
don't look at me answer was written that
way in the script erect penis hair here
is a Romulan representative in fact
they're all representatives of their
governments and they meet up in this
shithole of a location or they can find
our place to meet to lay out exposition
20 years ago our three governments agree
to develop this planet together our new
age died a quick death but there's sucks
to be them speech is interrupted by
cyclic our governments will stop at
nothing to ensure our safety that's
exactly what I'm counting on we didn't
come back to camp hammy where's Spock
bones and Kirk all sit around the
fireplace eating beans
don't stay too close to us back there
these are from an old southern recipe
handed down to me by my father that case
I have little choice but the sample
you've been ooh
bourbon and beans an explosive
combination with that Vulcan metabolism
he could eat a bowl of termites and it
wouldn't bother mmm you know you two
could drive a man to drink you really
piss me off Jim okay the whiskey away
from him he's clearly had his fill maybe
didn't cross that might your mind
viewers but you should have been killed
when you fell off that mountain
not another thing what's up with the
three tenets cat lady had earlier
I knew I wouldn't die because the to you
will I do not understand
I've always known I'll die alone
or with a bold man trapped under a
bridge gasping for air but I know it's
one of those two just be fair that is a
pretty deep scene to have in a Star Trek
movie
what's it leading up to I believe we are
required to engage in a ritual known as
the sing-along I haven't sung around the
campfire since I was a boy in Iowa what
are we gonna sing what bonk what are we
gonna say how about camptown races pack
up your troubles
moon over Rygel seven row row your boat
row row row your I love row did you know
row row row row row your boat that song
does not come up in my research captain
the lyrics are very simple it's row row
row your boat um is this really worth
playing over the hostage theme that we
had going on earlier I don't know if I
see the necessity merrily merrily
merrily merrily life is but a dream the
doctor and I will start it up and then
when we give you a signal you jump in
doctor if you please mmm don't say I
didn't warn you
waiting really building up this musical
interpretation aren't they row row row
your boat gently down the stream
roll it really merrily merrily lightly
down the street everybody are we really
spending so much time on this wasn't
there some government representatives
that were threatened with death why are
we still here merrily merrily merrily
merrily life come on Spock why didn't
you jump in I was trying to comprehend
the meaning of the words I'm trying to
comprehend the meaning of the scene it's
a song you're green-blooded Vulcan life
is not a dream no you're right it's a
series of questions leading up to
inevitably asking what the hell am i
doing sitting around a fire blazing in
broken fucking hell
goodnight bones good night gem too much
fun good night doctor night spot good
night Jim good night children good night
dad good night Karen like the night
JimBob goodnight Elizabeth
meanwhile we cut to a crazy Klingon
who's just
well bored so he looks for creepy shit
to do riveting subplot huh - yeah what
that Nimoy's quoted a person pod
yakov oh fuck you big dude sure yeah and
he might get his wish
surely if it appears as canceled due to
the hostage situation and the crew are
flown back all I ask is a tall ship
start is stare by Melville John mister
are you sure about it I am well versed
in the classics doctor and how come you
don't know row row row your boat come on
we get your finger again yes we have a
partnership operation of two weeks again
two three what up I think you gave me
too much time captain wrist
I could use a shower
yes well it wasn't nearly as important
as the row row row your boat seen but I
still see the necessity in my line Hill
to dress us off right could you do there
is a job so the ship has all sorts of
problems and odds and sods that aren't
fixed yet but that doesn't stop the
Federation from sending what seems like
the only captain they ever send for
anything now I know Enterprise is not
exactly up to specs the enterprise is a
disaster there must be other ships in
the quadrant other ships yes but no
experienced commanders captain I need
Jim Kirk well why don't you take a shit
that's another disaster and book her on
that what's manager I miss my old sure
okay it's a writing from Little Rascals
your name John surveys actually it does
feel like The Little Rascals no
seriously Spock's reaction just just
like the dog isn't it I'm just I want
you oh look we don't see the hostage
footage that Sybok has sent out your
question you've done the Federation
Starship barley for our leads at once I
deeply regret this desperate act but
these are desperate times I have no
desire to harm these innocents but do
not put me to the test I'm fine okay
every day he doesn't people will die oh
and by the way when did Baltimore get
there was a representative of Hogwarts
on that planet too oh so because the
teleporter isn't working they take a
shovel down to see if they can sneak it
shuttle from who framed roger rabbit
apparently but in order to sneak in they
need a distraction
oh god no no no no no chatter have you
no shame I'll pull the camera back go no
closer go to closer God God Oh closer oh
god I can see your anus why would you do
this Shatner while I quick put some
clothes on that woman Frank give me your
oh no Bemidji wants me I'll be better
god it's gotta be something I can just
do what calendar girls is going on how
long is the scene perfect Sandra
Corporate America
so kind of an snap no anyway it's a
dance over
Oh God
hello boys I've always wanted to play to
encapsulate for the love of God don't
rape us
well that's going on check off is
distracting sight by pretending to be
the captain of the ship while Kirk and
the other sneak in well they're gone
Spock moved your horse captain no you
didn't say that it is I refuse to
believe the line that stupid is in Star
Trek movie moves your horse don't play
it again
I'm already repressed it it's gone you
played a clip all I'm gonna see is
response do you me definitely I could do
that for the Aurora dance don't work
even as we speak a Klingon warship is on
the stage he estimated I will within the
hour
I imagine the Klingons will be quite
angry you're under attack by superior
Federation force it wasn't bloodshed I
won't wait come back I not done
mispronouncing thing
hand over all your Westley webbing and
number five on Shatner's very bizarre
bucket list finally gets fulfilled
that's right cats don't dance no more
pussyfooting around and forget it shake
it Cheetara
oh let's face it it's better than lose
your horse captain I at least gave you
the option of three date but it turns
out Sybok has used his power to
brainwash the hostages and now they have
Kirk captured as well
Sybok and Spock recognize each other as
old friends from long ago but spot still
refuses to join it thus they're forced
to fly Sybok back to their ship allow
the lead singer of kids closes in on to
get us inside and we raise the shields
will take exactly fifteen point five
seconds an eternity
during which we'll be vulnerable to
Klingon attack he speaks the truth wait
a minute don't they have a Klingon
general there why don't they just use
him to tell the guy to stand out flyer
in men or this works too what
so Kirk Spock and bones are put in the
ship's prison while Sybok continues to
brainwash the crew by taking away their
pain but we also find out some very
interesting info I ordered you to defend
your ship you ordered me to kill my
brother you mean he's your brother
brother
Sybok couldn't possibly be your brother
because I happen to know for a fact you
don't have a brother
technically you are correct yeah you see
I have a half-brother so what I told you
was true from a certain point of view
yeah they pulled the off you never asked
Rick just so they can connect these two
together honestly the story would have
worked just as well and they were close
friends instead of brothers but screw it
doesn't matter what I might be the plan
my Vulcan ancestors were ruled by their
emotions they believed in a place in
which these questions of existence would
be answered the greatest adventure of
all time the discovery of chakra
galaxies so and I swear I'm not kidding
here Sybok is literally looking for God
oh and I don't mean in a spiritual sense
or look within yourself no I need
physically locate him find out where
he's been hiding and he thinks that
God's been covering up heaven for all
these years behind something called the
Great Barrier shit has ever gone into
the great barrier probes of a return oh
and don't think I'm misinterpreting that
this is God or heaven because he
literally uses those terms later place
from which creation sprang heaven Eden
call it what you will
God's a busy man yeah kinda hard to
believe they're really going here I mean
it's pretty hard not to be let down when
you're being promised God in your movie
that's kind of a lot of buildup what are
you setting out on the part you're not
going jails like when you see one look
Scotty break them out of their cell and
tell them where he thinks they can get a
de-stressing the left and is it me or if
the policeman of those pipes really kind
of stupid mr. Scott you're amazing
nothing amazing about it I know this
ship like the back of my hand
they start climbing to get to their
location but spot believes he has found
a faster way I believe I found a faster
way oh and never mind the obvious shadow
of the lived holding him up I'm sure
it's just the shadow that really Beth
wallet in his back pocket or something
but it appears we're too heavy must've
those marshmallows fire the rocket what
was the order of the deck way past fifty
to sixty four sixty three fifty two
again seventy seven seventy eight
seventy eight again and then the seal Oh
No why did you stop
apparently the layout of the ship is
like a video game glitch keep going
higher and higher and yet somehow you
keep getting lower and lower go further
feeling I'm sure you'll end up at the
floor again but they're caught once
again and Sybok decides to have a little
chant I want your respect are you afraid
to hear me out
wait outside okay
beat him up come on guys outnumber him
three to one
he has no weapon just hold a knife up to
his throat and say give me back the
goddamn ship you pointed year Sean
Connery your pain is the deepest of all
I can feel it at you but instead we see
sci-fi try to take away the pain of
bones and Spock in the wholesome winning
them to his side oh god don't do this to
me
I'm here I'm with you dad
now don't be fair this scene is very
well done as we see the pains our
characters suffer and even discover that
many times our pain helps in forming who
we are and it bones your doctor you know
the pain and kills can be taken away
with a wave of a magic wand other things
we carry with us the things that make us
who we are I don't want my pain taken
away I need my pain prepare enough
statement but all I'm thinking is how
about fuckity making these images appear
he never did in the opening and you
never see it with anyone else and we're
told it's not just inside their minds as
clearly all four of them can see the
visuals and on top of that where did
this power come from anyway it's not my
psychiatry where he talks to him he just
sort of looked for them and the pain
goes away where do you want to do a
how's it being accomplished never
addressed we just assume that he's a
Vulcan Jesus oh Jesus
I found myself and my place I Know Who I
am I cannot go with you so much brain
watching doesn't seem to work on them
but they decide to join them anyway
because they're as curious as he is um
you sure you didn't bring worship
[Music]
they say gnosis can survive I say
they're wrong I say the danger is an
illusion
[Music]
well apparently it is an illusion
because not only do they make it through
with no problem whatsoever I mean the
ship doesn't even shake let me literally
do it in the span of just a couple of
seconds the great danger they were
talking about we're all the shifts in
the galaxy just like da looks dangerous
and never went in tennis blowers are
these the boldly go where no man is a
bullshit too cowardly run away from
anything that looks different the Great
Barrier is about as threatening as the
ring of fire from Finding Nemo
terrifying so they take a shuttle down
to Planet heaven come across something
it appears when the remains of a
brontosaurus burger captain this is the
voice of God one voice
[Music]
pursue your expectations
the Cowardly Lion is God I'm the Messiah
I'm gonna fire hallelujah
actually it was disgustingly easy kind
of like stepping through a life fog and
cuz if you breach the barrier with a
starship couldn't carry
excuse me yes Kirk do you ingeniously
want to point out the Pinkley obvious
what does God's leave with the starship
bring the ship I said what does God need
with a starship I think the real
question is what does Kirk me with a
wire strapped to his back
why is God angry he's not answered his
question what does God need with a
starship
all right I'm convinced he's God
I must have now to be fair according to
most text God has asked for a lot of
bizarre things Jesus time across that
Abraham kill your son Moses wander
through the desert for about 40 years
asking for a starship almost sounds
reasonable
an eternity I've been imprisoned given
this choice but they are now convinced
that this is not any God at all so what
is he then reveal yourself
[Music]
wrong don't you like this face what a
twist
I don't even get it it's him but it's
not him they never really explained it
this is my doing this is my arrogance my
vanity I am you and you are me I am you
you and me
I am yo so Sybok tries to fight off the
whatever and Turk has his ship fire
torpedo at it it kills Sybok but doesn't
seem to destroy the entity but the
teleporter starts working but can only
beam up to people so Kirk says beam up
Spock and balls
[Music]
scooby-dooby know what's not Klingon
ship arrived funny I get that to ship
that made it through the horrifying
great barrier and destroys the beast
with his laser gun so a photon torpedo
barely hurts it but a few shots from a
tiny laser cute little logical he said
beamed aboard the ship where it turns
out that spot convinced the Klingon
general to outrank the crazy guy chasing
him just like they should have done
before God cares the movies almost over
lets just hear our half-assed moral that
even VeggieTales could tell us it's gone
really out there maybe he's not out
there but maybe he's right here
human heart well one place he definitely
isn't it in this script why because no
loving God would ever let us end on this
scene are you fucking serious
you're really bringing it back to this
scene like this was the big favorite in
all the movie you know what when it
stays this way it doesn't seem play
nothing happens
bones did we do a weird thing where we
search for God and Spock lost his
brother it's not mentioned in the next
Star Trek movie I don't care
[Music]
well life is planet roll roll the
credits quickly cross the scree or
banking who slow a Star Trek five and
let me tell you for a movie about
finding God really feel like nothing was
accomplished it turns it can have some
good moments even some good character
development but a lot of the scenes
don't tie together a lot of characters
he pointless the comedy is really bad
and plus the story is just beyond
ridiculous it's closer to finding God in
history of the world part one than I do
it is still Dan granted the next film is
a lot better but we still have a whole
nother generation of movies to fuck it
up
I love it sounds a critic I remember it
so you don't have to
[Music]
I have little choice but sample your
being